[Inaudible]
you ready to go to work
on August 11th, 2020?
There are just over 80 days until the U S elections will be held.
And when democratic candidate Juul Biden,
I noticed the name of the person accompanying him on his election tickets.
I have the great honor to announce that I've picked Kamala Harris,
a fearless fighter for the little guy at one of the country's finest public
servants. As my running mate, Joe Biden on Twitter.
And as the announcement is made the Republican party,
or at least president Trump's political machine opened fire.
Kamala Harris is election has completed the takeover of the party by the extreme
left wing and its radical agenda. Marsha Blackburn Senator for Tennessee,
Joe Biden is no moderate. And with Harris and his political living well,
he is surrendering control of our nation to the radical mob with promises to
raise taxes, not to police funding, Hill energy jobs,
open our borders and appease socialistic, taters, Katrina Pierson,
the Trump campaign's 2020 senior advisor,
Joe Biden's decision to add Kamala Harris to the tickets,
confirms everything president Trump and I have been saying,
and that is that Joe Biden and the democratic party have been overtaken by the
radical left. Mike Pence, vice president of the United States.
She is a disaster. She's going to be a disaster, I think for their party.
I agree with you. I believe Congress should act. I agree.
I heard actually she's the most liberal person in all of Congress.
That's what I've heard more liberal than Bernie Sanders. Believe it or not.
I give credit to Bernie Sanders for starting a very important discussion,
but it became clear to me that we could do better. And so my Medicare,
for all plan,
it allows Americans to have choice between a Medicare for all public plan
or a Medicare for all private plan.
Cause I heard from people they want to have choice.
They don't want private plans to be excluded.
She was very, very nasty.
She was extraordinarily nasty to Kevin.
Archie was the meanest
the most horrible most disrespectful? No, it's actually a question.
So my visual politic nerd is the strategy of Republicans.
Following the election of Kamala.
Harris has been clear to point her out as a radical left-wing candidate. Oh,
knew a person from the most extremely socialist recesses of the democratic party
faced with this approach. However, media outlets such as the New York times,
the Los Angeles times and the ABC have painted her as quite the opposite as a
centrist and moderate candidate and impression that according to the polls is
the same one that the voters have.
Voters see Harris as more moderate than Trump or Pence morning consult.
And that is not all political analysis groups found that Harris's withdrawal
from the democratic primary was largely due to the lack of enthusiasm.
Her candidacy generated among the parties extreme left wing,
and a primary race loaded with moderate candidates, speeding.
To the Pueblo and out of a love for all people. I hear by second,
the nomination of Senator Bernard Sanders of Vermont.
Questions we are asking today are what is really behind all of this.
What point of view is closest to reality and take notes because the answers to
these questions are particularly important when you consider things like this.
Biden plans to make Harris as powerful a Veep as he was under Obama,
democratic nominee was one of the most impactful vice presidents ever or in
policy.
So my political aficionados, who exactly as Kamala Harris,
why did Biden choose her as his running mate?
What applications could it have for the future?
Are we looking at a future female president of the United States and the most
important question of all,
what exactly does the person who might be in charge of one of the most important
vice presidencies and the history of American democracy stand for in this video,
we are going to answer all of those questions and we will do so specifically by
taking a look at the political work that this candidate has done so far.
And I'll tell you know,
that we are going to come across a little bit of everything, but first,
first we have to see exactly who Kamala Harris is.
So listen to
an American story.
California and Senator and former attorney general of the same state Harris as a
stalwart fan of converse sneakers. Of course,
that is not our most American feature. My friends Kamala Harris,
his personal profile is something of a mixed bank made up of many of the
attributes that embody contemporary society. And in particular,
the one known as the American dream Harris is a perfect representative of
the multi-racial multi-ethnic and multicultural currents that shaped much of
American society today. And Joe Biden's words,
her story is the story of America. Now just one moment,
let's actually look at that story
Because Kamala Harris was born in 1964 and the California city of Oakland
as city located in the San Francisco Bay area that has become a melting pot of
ethnic minorities. Only 20% of its inhabitants are white Americans.
The fact is Kamala Harris is the biracial daughter of a couple of newly arrived
immigrants, her father Jamaican,
and her mother Indian two immigrants who came to the country when very young and
over the years became very successful.
Her father ended up teaching economics at Stanford and her mother worked as a
cancer researcher. Not only that,
they also actively participated in the civil rights movement led by Martin
Luther King.
That was the environment in which the second vice presidential candidate was
raised. But that is not all after her presidents divorced,
Kamala spent her teenage years and Montreal and later attended Howard
university, a historically black institution and Washington DC.
Soon after she returned to California and began her legal career fighting crime,
a career that led her to be elected as San Francisco district attorney in 2004
and later in the 2010 election as California state attorney,
she was reelected to this position in 2014 and ended up being elected to the
Senate and the 2016 election. Okay.
So in a nutshell, an African-American Indian daughter of immigrants,
a poster child for social mobility and married to a white man of Jewish faith to
top it all off. She is a Democrat who has built her career.
I run the fight against crime and as a and supporter of the Israeli state.
I stand with Israel because of our shared values,
which are so fundamental to the founding of both our nations.
And as long as I'm a United States, Senator,
I will do everything in my power to ensure broad and
bi-partisan support for Israel security and right to self-defense.
You might be thinking here,
if we had to design from scratch the profile of a candidate for a contemporary
political series or not of one who embodied the American dream like new other,
I'm sure the result would look a lot like Kamala Harris, his profile, of course,
none of these things are her most important attributes, nor are the,
any guarantee of anything, obviously,
but they are attributes that function as a kind of symbol and symbols are
usually very significant in American society.
And they also explain to a large extent why Juul Biden has chosen her
specifically. Let's think about this for one second.
Biden is almost 78 years old and she is 55.
Biden is from the East coast and she is from the West Baden like Trump and Pence
are white men.
And she's a woman and is part of two minorities African-American and Indian
Biden as a reputation as a centrist and Harris as a moderate.
But that combination pushes a little more to the left. That is in other words,
she is the perfect compliment to Biden's candidacy.
And you know what Paul's say exactly the same thing.
Kamala Harris is more popular than biotin among women, young people,
and very importantly, amongst black voters.
And don't forget the low participation of the African-American voters in 2016
was one of the things that cost Hillary Clinton, the presidency,
but my friends haven't come this far.
I think the time has no come to ask ourselves the key question,
how the left wing is Kamala Harris or to put it more diplomatically.
What policies does she stand for?
And why is this something that could be so important to the United States?
Listen up.
A little bit of everything.
My friends for most of the history of the United States,
vice presidents have had virtually no influence the vice presidency.
It was essentially a considered an empty position of responsibility and merely
honorary and most cases they didn't even participate in government meetings.
They were only there in case anything happened to the president.
The vice-president is the most insignificant office ever conceived by the human
mind. John Adams, vice president of George Washington,
and second president of the United States.
The vice president of the United States is like a man in a catalytic state.
He can not speak, he could not move. He suffers no pain.
And yet he is perfectly conscious of everything that is going on about him.
Thomas Riley, Marshall vice-president of Woodrow. Okay.
And I thought, I hated my job before coming to work here. Hello,
let's take a minute because this is something that has been changing in the 21st
century And recent administrations.
The role of the vice president has been quite significant actually, for example,
Dick Cheney with George W.
Bush and Joe Biden with Barack Obama had a lot of influence and were responsible
for some of the most important policies during those administrations.
So should Biden become the 46th president of the United States?
The vice president could be one of the most important,
if not the most important in the country's history. Why? Well,
check out new stories like this.
Off of Democrats, don't think Biden will serve all four years.
A majority of voters,
including half of Democrats do not think that 77 year old Democrats,
Joe Biden will serve all four years as president Washington exam.
Let's assume however that he does complete his first term ever elected.
Of course,
the truth is the Biden would be facing the next campaign almost 82 years old,
82 years on the planet. That's kind of a long.
And you think that makes it virtually a given the Juul Biden would not aspire to
reelection.
And then the administration could therefore devote much of its efforts to
boosting a candidate who would continue his work. The vice president.
That is why at these particular elections,
it's more important to know what Mrs. Kamala Harris is thinking and standing
for. So my friends.
Let's get into it.
Kamala Harris, more liberal than Bernie Sanders.
Senate record analysis shows Newsweek.
Our ideology score plays to Kamala Harris is the most liberal Senator in
2019 dove track and independent and non-partisan project.
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa. Just wait one minute. The most left wing Senator.
So are Republicans, right? When they accused Jairus of being a radical well, no,
the truth has no, no, exactly.
Or rather we have to be careful with these types of rankings because they are
based on a very general premise,
not to mention when you're in campaign mode,
you sometimes support things that you wouldn't stick with.
If a decision is really at stake and the truth is Senator Harris,
ideologically is not very far to the left, at least not in every matter.
So let me explain one of the most important issues and where we are going to see
the biggest differences between the center and the left wing of the democratic
party occupied currently with the lakes of Bernie Sanders, Alexandria Ocasio,
Cortez,
and Elizabeth Warren is in the issue of what else taxes you see
both Senator and former democratic primary candidate,
Elizabeth Warren and Joe Biden's new partner,
what the tax system to be more progressive, but as always,
they want to achieve this end very different ways. You know,
the saying the devil is in.
The detail.
And as you'll see the tax proposals from these two senators could not be more
different while Elizabeth Warren advocates carrying out massive tax increases
and setting new taxes,
such as a wealth tax to finance badly underfunded utilities,
Kamala Harris proposed the so-called left. The middle-class act.
This law would increase the escalation of the tax through a sharp drop in taxes
on the middle classes and on lower income households. Senator Harris,
his proposal is to pass a refundable tax credit of up to $3,000 for single
people and $6,000 for married couples. To get this credit,
you have to have a job and earn less than a hundred thousand dollars a year to
give you an idea.
This would actually mean a tax cut of nearly 300 billion a year that would
benefit about 18 million Americans.
The idea of this refundable credit is as follows. For example,
if your tax bill amongst the $5,000 in federal taxes and you're eligible for
this $3,000 credit, you don't have to pay the difference $2,000. And if,
for example,
you only have to pay $1,000 in taxes because you have a very low salary.
State gives you the difference.
It's a formula that already exists in the United States and has worked
relatively well because you have to have a job to receive these benefits.
Let's just say it's a clear incentive to become part of the workforce. In fact,
experience tells us the programs that are already underway have increased
employment,
and therefore the collection of taxes related to work and excise duty
This while reducing the demand for other social benefits.
The result is that the cost of these two programs already underway has been
relatively low. So you may or may not link such plans,
but they are pretty far from radical left-wing policies. On the contrary,
in fact, Harris,
his proposal is a bigger tax cut than promised by Donald Trump himself.
It's just going to the little guy instead of the big one.
And while it is true that she wants to finance it by reversing parts,
if only parts of the Trump reform and also setting a tax on financial
transactions,
the final result of Biden's vice president's proposal would mean a significant
tax cut, whichever way you look at it
As always another one of the most important and controversial fields in America
is that of health Kamala Harris.
Co-sponsored the Medicare for all act introduced by Bernie Sanders,
a bill that proposed to completely eliminate private insurance.
This was a topic that generated so much controversy that the Senator ended up
presenting her own plan,
a plan that dead maintain the role of private insurers and the Medicare system,
but which strengthened public insurance and above all advanced that increasingly
widespread idea and the democratic party of transforming the American system and
to a single payer system that is a system with universal healthcare.
Like many of us have here in good old Europe where you eat,
don't think that you should die. If you don't have enough money or radical.
The only thing that Kamala Harris doesn't detail is how to pay for all this
transformation in front of her, however, is the Baden plan.
And it's not exactly along the same lane,
but the truth is that the Senator for California doesn't seem to have the
slightest problem. There.
She is a pragmatist
and yes.
Is true.
Apparently she has some possessions that are perhaps a little more to the left
and politics have normally been comfortable with in the United States.
And when it comes to the crunch, as also happened with Obama,
she has always been in claims to reconcile these ideas with the interest of
different sectors, including the business world. And maybe that is why,
and this election, both Silicon Valley on wall street,
it was famously socialists institutions are behind the Baden and Harris'
candidacy. Yeah, you heard that correctly. In fact,
wall street financers are donating a lot more money to Biden's candidacy than to
Trump's. But beyond these two issues, perhaps Kamala Harris,
his most controversial policies include our support for the naturalization of
illegal immigrants,
her defense being that it has to be easier to get the country to go to work and
her commitment to investing a lot of money and the environment and fighting
climate change.
First. And it's important to know.
I do disagree with a lot of the things on your platform and others,
and I am a Republican.
I know you're here because you love our country and I'm here for the same
reason.
And I know that about you because you're here right now and you had the courage
to stand up and say what you said. And that means a lot.
Fair to Kamala Harris.
This has been a constant throughout retirement and the Senate promise more and
more public spending commitments and total,
according to estimates by Brian Rodale,
a budget expert at the Manhattan Institute, Harris has proposed 46 trillion,
yes,
with a T 46 trillion and new public spending over the next decade.
Evidently not even sheep.
The Senator herself thinks it is possible to carry out everything she has voted
for or promised.
And the main problem with this is not only that it can lead to disappointed
expectations,
but above all her discourse creates is the perfect breeding ground for the
so-called more radical rhetoric such as that of Bernie Sanders are Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez to become the norm.
She may be much more moderate than she is painted by the Republican party.
But so far,
she has not contributed to the slightest to strengthening that moderate base
within the democratic party.
But my friends,
if Kamala Harris were to become the 47th president of the United States,
her main move for sure would be the reform of the United States,
judicial police and criminal system,
something which based on all available data relating to criminality,
police negligence and prison populations,
topics that we have already spoken to you about here at length on visual politic
is really very lacking
Topic.
Harris supports plans to reduce prison sentences and exchange for job training
or reintegration programs.
She wants to improve police training and limit police impunity,
or their ability to use force measure.
She also wants to legalize marijuana at the federal level abolish the death
penalty and to end the cash bail bond system that forces people to serve years
and remand before even facing trial,
simply for not having the money to buy bail. In fact,
she presented just such an initiative and the Senate alongside Republican
Senator Rand, Paul,
And make no mistake.
This move shows us that we are not looking at the typical democratic candidate
who does not want to face up to crane.
Many of these proposed initiatives really do make a lot of sense.
You can be firm,
but you can also think about constructive ways of solving problems.
Not everything has to be scaring people's straights. For example,
when she was California's attorney general and an effort to reduce absenteeism
and improve academic outcomes,
she led an initiative to prosecute parents whose children were systematically
missing from school. Something, which by the way,
many Republicans liked a lot, but not so much the left wing Democrats. In fact,
her heavy haunted rule in California is one of the things that the left wing
factions most criticized. Anyway, there you have it, a profile of Kamala Harris,
a candidate who does as is true.
It seemed to be a little farther to the left and the U S politics has ever been
in the past. She's basically a European conservative,
but I'm sure we'll have the opportunity to talk about her on many more
occasions. So now it's your turn. What did you think about Kamala Harris?
Do you think we'll get to see her sitting in the oval office one day.
Don't forget to leave all your answers underneath in the comments as always.
We really hope you've enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to hit a little alarm down there so you can get updates.
Whenever we release new videos, we release them every couple of days. Also,
if you like this kind of thing, I have a podcast called making Europe grants.
Again, you can find on Spotify, iTunes, wherever you get your podcasts. Finally,
this channel is possible because of Patrion on our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you next time.
[Inaudible].